[Musique]
as tu nous avais parlé d'un pompier oui
qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce pompier
tu peux reprendre depuis lors c'est un
pompier qui dit à sa femme écoute on va
faire comment la caserne quand je te
dise si rennes 1 tu te déshabille pas
que des sirènes de tu sautes d'anlier et
quand je dis si rennes 3 on n'y voit
pour la nuit
donc le soir venu ils crient ciel 1 elle
se dévêtit la faune sedan lycienne de
plonge dans le lit sir l3 et commence à
faire l'amour au bout de deux minutes
est la crise irène 4-4 il dit mais
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est quoi si
rennes 4 à lui dire ajoute du tuyau tu
es trop loin du feu la c1 à rabat un
français un américain qui se base sur
une page et sur une plage il croise un
génie il induit un total de 13 ans jenny
et le génie leur dit vous allez chacun
votre tour lancé quelque chose dans
l'océan
si je le retrouve je vous tue deux sur
le coup après sont pas ni pas le génie
dias ouais mec sans panique est tous des
[ __ ] ce pas positif du tout le
français commence qui fouille dans sa
poche et trouve une toute petite tour
est fait comme ça
il lance la toute petite tour eiffel en
plein milieu de l'océan le génie va y
chercher chercher chercheurs il trouve
la petite tour eiffel il arrive vite le
français les deux ils sont comme ça ils
sont sous le choc
comment on va faire on va faire à
l'américaine voilà il fouille dans sa
poche il trouve un petit corps dans
comme ça il jette le petit kurdes en
plein milieu de l'océan
le génie cherche y cherche y cherchent
ils cherchent ils trouvent une petite
cure dents y vas y tu l'américain et as
l'arabe dans sa poche comme ça il jette
quelque chose en plein milieu de l'océan
le génie cher chiche rg cher richert s'y
trouve pas il revient avant l'arabie
mais qu'est ce que tu as jeté barabé
d'image jeter un efferalgan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça démarre fort très très bonne ça alors
c'est c'est un char assiste donc et qui
est très très raciste et
et qui décident d'aller contre ces
préjugés
donc il dit bon allez cheval à la
mosquée peut-être que c'est pas comme je
pense peut-être que voilà il dirigera la
mosquée d'où qui va à la mosquée le
vendredi et où il s'assoit avec vous il
enlève ses chaussures est et comment si
c'est le discours de l'imam commence et
où il se sent un petit peu quand même
apaisé spirituellement et due place pas
mal et où les mêmes marche dans les
rangs comme ça elle va le voir et lui
mes amants sur le front comme ça et lui
dit tu vas marché le raciste city mais
attention je comprends pas je n'ai pas
de problème de motricité moi je vais
marcher je comprends pas la prière
commence la prière finie sort et ils
voient qu'on lui a volé sa voiture
[Rires]
c'est une famille qui va dans un camp
nudiste et le petit garçon il demande à
son papa il y parlera pourquoi il ya des
hommes qui ont des gros zizi et pourquoi
il ya d'autres hommes qui ont des petits
zizis son père riba écoute c simple je
vais t'expliquer tous les hommes qui ont
un petit zizi sont pauvres et tous les
hommes qui ont un gros zizis sont riches
il lui dit ah ok lui dit mais pourquoi
tu me pose cette question il dit parce
que tout à leur maman parlé avec un
monsieur très très pauvres qui est
devenu très riche en cinq minutes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et là le père il est très inquiet lui
dit m'attend mais une question me
raconter l uta merle a eu dix ans mais
t'inquiète pas papa est là en train de
lui sucer tout son pognon là
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est un arabe et un gitan qui
rentre dans une boulangerie de copains
c'est un arabe un gitan qui rendent
boulangerie et ayant dans la boulangerie
et la râpe rentes weeks très très vite
et le met dans sa poche et regarde les
gitans comme say it a vu la classe
justin lui dit attendons juste montrer
c'est quoi la classe c'est nous les
gitans c'est nous les meilleurs il dit
ok le jt regarde la boulangère comme
s'ils y donnez moi un tweak s'il vous
plaît à lui de 28 x
il ouvre le luxe comme ça et mangent les
tweaks et regarde la boulangère tu l'as
fixe dans les jets mon succès il finit
son tweaks hermange le deuxième le
deuxième héros prend 2 m il mange de
deuxième alors gars comme ça du bon ça
assez duré c'est quoi le tour de magie
il dit maintenant regarder dans la poche
de l'arabe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu
on n'a pas été déçu
[Applaudissements]